this week we're talking about kubernetes
cloud native and networking welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news we recently
talked about how kubernetes apps in the
GCP marketplace make it easier to find
and deploy commercial or open source
apps managing our building kubernetes
applications takes a lot of effort which
is why kubernetes operators help
standardize and make the process easier
the application custom resource
definition includes a standard API for
creating viewing and managing
applications in kubernetes giving you
well-defined ways to interact with and
manage your deployed apps read more
about these kubernetes operators and see
them in action on the GCP marketplace
after all kubernetes has played a major
role in helping developers build cloud
native but there's many projects that
have been redeveloped and released in
the open source communities such as stok
native and cube flow check out this blog
post that talks more about what these
tools do and how they can help you build
a cloud native future for a more
traditional application cloud native can
sometimes feel overwhelming if you're
familiar with any application that's one
part web server and one part database
such as a traditional lamp app check out
this new solution for migrating your
two-tier application to GCP it presents
all the central planning questions
you'll need to have answered ahead of
time then makes the case for various
compute and database options if you want
to learn more about migrating there's no
better place to start looking to do some
serious networking it takes a lot for
Google's global network to handle
billions of users a day and that's the
same network you get on your Google
cloud projects check out this networking
deep dive on the different load
balancing options and how Google makes
them work keep the date with more
networking deep dives on the Google
cloud blog and networking end to end on
the GCP youtube channel if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you